(car engine revving)
- You don't have to, like, move yourself.
(tires squealing)
(car crashes)
(upbeat techno music)
(clock ticking)
(alarm beeping)
- Hmm, can I go to the gym?
(upbeat techno music)
(energetic game music)
- Well, what are you getting
Devon for her birthday?
- A GTX 780 graphics processor.
It should improve her render time
by like 15%.
(upbeat techno music)
- My choice for MVP is Prince Fielder.
- Oh, my God.
That guy's a total glass cannon.
I mean, with a horrible DPS,
like, maybe if he had the taking
power of a barbarian
he'd be a decent player,
but I wouldn't recommend
putting him on the field.
(upbeat techno music)
- Oh, good play, good play, good play.
No, no, what are you doing?
Oh, my God.
- You watching the game?
(indistinct speech)
(upbeat techno music)
[Both] Five nights at Freddie's.
- You play?
- I play, of course I play.
(upbeat techno music)
- It is up to you
to roll a 15 in order to kill
the last knoll.
- I didn't want to have to do this.
(dice clanking on table)
(ominous thud)
(upbeat techno music)
(car engine revving)